Queridos amigos, cuando hablamos del
Ejército ruso en Ucrania, en realidad
es como si estuviéramos hablando de un cuerpo
con 3 cabezas ¿Y cuales son estas tres cabezas?
Por un lado , tenemos el ejército regular,
del que hemos hablado largo y tendido aquí
en VisualPolitik. Por el otro está Kadirov,
el líder Checheno, del que también hemos
dado cuenta en VisualPolitik. Un hombre
conocido por sus vídeos en redes sociales.
Pero hay una tercera cabeza en la que
nos vamos a centrar en el vídeo de hoy:
YEVGENY PRIGOZHIN: el dueño del Grupo Wagner,
la empresa de mercenarios más importante de
Rusia. Un oligarca ruso en toda regla… pero
muy distinto a los demás. A diferencia de los
silovikis de los que hemos hablado ya, que
son gente con formación y perfil tecnócrata,
Prigozhin tiene un pasado mucho más oscuro.
Cuando preparamos este vídeo, una de las últimas
apariciones públicas de este oligarca ha sido
lanzar este mensaje al presidente Zelensky para
que el Ejército de Ucrania y la población
civil abandonen sus posiciones en Bakhmut.
El protagonismo que han adquirido tanto Prigozhin
como el grupo Wagner en la guerra es francamente
sorprendente, ya que parecen los únicos capaces
de lograr avances en Ucrania. Pero la sensación
que deja es de falta de coordinación; es como
si hubiera 3 ejércitos distintos compitiendo
por conquistar Ucrania y ver quién hace
más méritos ante los ojos de Putin:
Si las fuerzas regulares de Shoigu, si
los kadyrovtsky chechenos de Kadyrov o
el Grupo Wagner, el ejército privado
de Prigozhin. Así que la pregunta es:
¿Por qué Rusia necesita un ejército privado?
¿A qué se dedica el Grupo Wagner? ¿Quién
es Prigozhin y cuanto poder tiene en
la Rusia de Putin? Hoy en VisualPolitik
vamos a responder a estas preguntas. Pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1(¿QUIÉN QUIERE UN EJÉRCITO PRIVADO?)
La gran pregunta es para qué quiere Rusia un
ejército privado si ya tiene el suyo. Además,
normalmente la guerra la libran los Estados, por
lo que aparentemente no tiene ningún sentido.
Sin embargo, amigos, Rusia no es el primer
país que recurre a los ejércitos privados.
Mercenarios ha habido toda la vida. Ya los
había en tiempos de Alejandro Magno. Pero no
vayamos tan lejos. Hablemos de marzo de 2014,
cuando Rusia se anexó la península de Crimea.
Aquello no tuvo nada que ver con lo que todos
asociamos con una invasión. En este territorio
a orillas del mar Negro aparecieron de repente
los hombrecitos verdes. Hablamos de soldados
sin insignias ni distintivos que el Kremlin
nos quiso hacer creer que eran una especie de
simpatizantes de la causa rusa: civiles que habían
tomado las armas para llevar a cabo la anexión.
Obviamente, todos los identificamos como soldados
rusos, puesto que servían a los intereses de
Putin. De hecho, la actual guerra en Ucrania
ha confirmado estas sospechas. ¿O tal vez no?
(A día de hoy se piensa que los "pequeños
hombres verdes" eran una mezcla de algunos
agentes de las Fuerzas de Operaciones Especiales
y otras unidades del servicio de inteligencia
militar de las Fuerzas Armadas Rusas junto con
personal contratado del Grupo Wagner. No eran,
por tanto, fuerzas regulares de ningún ejército
oficial, sino una mezcla de espías y mercenarios.)
Aquí tenéis la principal razón por la que
cada vez más países están recurriendo a los
ejércitos privados: la negación verosímil.
Es decir, que las autoridades siempre pueden
negar la implicación del Estado en
las acciones de estos mercenarios,
especialmente en aquellas de
marcado carácter clandestino.
Por ejemplo, en el caso de los hombrecitos verdes,
si aquella operación no hubiera salido
bien, el Kremlin hubiera intentado
decirnos que ellos no tenían nada que ver
con ellos o que actuaban de forma aislada.
Pero, salió bien y gracias a
que la anexión de Crimea no se
vio cómo una agresión armada a Putin
prácticamente le salió gratis. ¿Todos
recordáis donde se celebró el Mundial
de Fútbol en 2018? ¿Verdad? Pues eso.
La cuestión es que los ejércitos privados están
de moda y alguno estará pensando: ¡Oh dios mío,
el neoliberalismo ha llegado al mun do militar!
¡Matones que se venden al mejor postor con la
de tiranos que hay en el mundo! Pues esperad un
momento, porque igual que Rusia recurre a Wagner,
Estados Unidos también ha utilizado a
los Blackwaters, ahora llamados Academi.
(En la Guerra de Irak, la administración
de George Bush utilizó intensamente los
servicios de corporaciones militares privadas
como Blackwater para aumentar rápidamente la
presencia militar estadounidense a medida que
la situación empeoraba. Claro que, algunas
informaciones sobre supuestos abusos perpetrados
por algunas fuerzas armadas de seguridad privada
contribuyeron a que la opinión pública les
percibiera como unos mercenarios irresponsables,
lo que abrió un polémico debate sobre su
supervisión y su falta de rendición de cuentas.)
Lo que ha hecho Estados Unidos con los Blackwater
en Irak o Afganistán habla directamente de otra de
las grandes ventajas que ofrecen estas compañías
militares: la flexibilidad. Un ejército privado
lo puedes utilizar en cualquier momento.
Si quieres usar tu ejército en cierto país
extranjero, seguramente haya que votarlo en el
parlamento, defenderlo ante la opinión pública.
Todo esto tiene un coste político,
la gente puede protestar. Obviamente,
esto importa más en una democracia.
Pero incluso aunque un tipo tan autoritario
como Putin quisiera ser opaco, para utilizar
al ejército regular ruso en el extranjero, su
Gobierno tiene que informar a la Duma. En cambio,
con una empresa privada, Putin no tiene
más que coger el teléfono y mandarles para
allá. Así actuaron por ejemplo en Siria,
donde el Grupo Wagner estaba peleando con
las fuerzas de Al-Asad en primera
línea. Mirad esta noticia de 2018.
(El Kremlin se desmarca de las informaciones
sobre muertes de mercenarios en Siria)
En este titular que acabamos de ver se junta
todo: flexibilidad, negación verosímil y otra
ventaja muy importante: las bajas no cuentan
igual si son del ejército regular o si son de
una empresa privada. Muchos estaréis pensando:
a ver Fonseca, los muertos, muertos son. Y sí,
tenéis razón. Pero para la opinión pública
no son lo mismo. Porque si cae un Marine,
es la Casa Blanca la que tiene que rendir
cuentas; si cae un Blackwater no.
Otro punto a favor de los ejércitos privados
es la misma que en cualquier otra colaboración
público-privada: si normalmente las subcontratas
buscan ser las más competitivas para llevarse
un contrato público, en el caso de las empresas
militares privadas sucede exactamente lo mismo.
(Y también podemos hablar de la experiencia. Antes
de la invasión de Ucrania, prácticamente la última
vez que había entrado en combate un soldado del
ejército regular de Rusia había sido durante los 5
días que duró el conflicto contra Georgia de hace
15 años. Por su parte, uno de Wagner es posible
que haya estado en los últimos años combatiendo en
Siria, Libia, Malí o la República Centroafricana)
De este modo estamos hablando de otra de
las ventajas de los ejércitos privados:
que sus miembros tienen más experiencia en
primera línea que un soldado regular. De hecho,
muchos de los integrantes del grupo Wagner son
antiguos miembros del ejército ruso e incluso
son veteranos de las guerras chechenas. Así que
todos estos son los motivos por los que están
floreciendo las empresas militares privadas a
lo largo del mundo y especialmente en Rusia.
En ocasiones interesa la negación verosímil,
la falta de rendición de cuentas,
la mayor flexibilidad para realizar
misiones semiclandestinas y
tener tropas más experimentadas.
Todo esto suena fantástico, ¿verdad? Pues
hay un problema: la Constitución rusa
prohíbe la creación de destacamentos armados
de carácter privado. Así que la pregunta es:
¿Cómo Putin se ha saltado las leyes rusas? ¿Quién
ha sido el tonto útil que lo ha hecho? Veámoslo.
T2(EL CHEF DE PUTIN)
A principios de la década pasada, Rusia
empezó a mostrar interés por las empresas
militares privadas. La cuestión es que
la ley rusa no las permite e incluso
está penado servir como mercenario. Aun así,
el propio Putin destacaba sus ventajas para
hacer realidad los intereses del Estado
sin su implicación. Y en la pista de lo
que iban a hacer nos puso Dmitry Rogozin,
por aquel entonces viceprimer ministro:
(“Estamos pensando si nuestro dinero fluirá para
financiar empresas militares de seguridad privada
extranjeras o consideraremos la viabilidad
de crear tales empresas dentro de la propia
Rusia y dar un paso en esta dirección. Dmitry
Rogozin, Viceprimer ministro de Rusia en 2012.)
La pregunta es ¿Quién estaba dispuesto a hacer
algo flagrantemente ilegal en Rusia? Los silovikis
que rodean a Putin no estaban por la labor. Tenían
demasiadas cosas que perder. Hacía falta un “tonto
útil”. Alguien con hambre de dinero… y poco
miedo a saltarse la ley. Esa persona estaba…
vendiendo perritos calientes en las calles de San
Petesburgo. ¡Os presento a… YEVGENY PRIGOZHIN!
(Después de pasar buena parte de los años 80 en
la cárcel, un puesto de comida callejera fue el
comienzo de todo un imperio gastronómico. La caída
de la URSS y la transición al capitalismo de Rusia
ofreció nuevas oportunidades a Prigozhin, que
con el tiempo abrió restaurantes de lujo como
el New Island, que se convirtió rápidamente en
el favorito de Vladimir Putin. Su cercanía con
el presidente ruso fue el origen de su fama hasta
el punto de ser conocido como el “Chef de Putin”.)
Ahora bien, una cosa es que tu strogonoff
esté de muerte y otra muy distinta es que
acabes siendo el jefe de los mercenarios rusos
¿Por qué se fijaron los silovikí en un oligarca
como Prigozhin para montar un ejército privado?
La respuesta la encontramos en el grupo Concord.
Concord es una empresa de catering de Prigozhin
que disfruta prácticamente de un monopolio en
los comedores escolares de Moscú, así
como en hospitales y cuarteles rusos.
Esta fue la vía por la que Prigozhin puso en
marcha al grupo Wagner. ¿Cuándo? Desde luego
en 2014 ya estaban en Crimea y en la guerra
separatista del Donbass que comenzó después.
Los datos empresariales
públicos nos dan muchas pistas:
el volumen de servicios prestados por
empresas relacionadas con Prigozhin y
el Ministerio de Defensa ruso pasó
de 11 millones de euros en 2014 a
1.000 millones en 2015. Y esto no es porque
Prigozhin empezara a darle caviar a la tropa.
Además, el campamento donde se entrena
el Grupo Wagner se ubica en una parcela
perteneciente al Ministerio de Defensa
en Molkin, cerca de Krasnodar. Por tanto,
los vínculos del Kremlin con Wagner son evidentes:
los silovikí acudieron a Prigozhin para financiar
un ejército privado. Y ahora les está
generando otro tipo de problemas.
("Como saben, San Petersburgo
está dirigido por una pandilla
de personas que se llenan los bolsillos y
no cumplen su palabra" Yevgeny Prigozhin.)
Prigozhin se siente libre para decir
lo que quiera. Incluso para arremeter
contra los silovikí. Se ha convertido
en alguien absolutamente incontrolable.
Al frente de Wagner, Prigozhin infunde miedo.
No es para menos viendo el historial de sus
mercenarios por medio mundo. Su especialidad
son las torturas salvajes y las ejecuciones
extrajudiciales. Y encima se graban en
vídeo para alardear. Os aseguro que a
su lado Quentin Tarantino es Sofia Coppola.
Y sí, he dicho en medio mundo porque claro,
cuando tienes un ejército privado, ya no
lo utilizas solo para Crimea o el Donbass.
(Mercenarios rusos buscan oro y
siembran el caos en África Central)
La República Centroafricana lleva
10 años inmersa en una guerra civil.
Su presidente recurrió al grupo Wagner
para instruir a sus tropas y garantizar
su seguridad personal. A cambio
les ofreció recursos naturales.
[Sobre la República Centroafricana os hemos
hablado, por cierto, hace muy poco tiempo en
NotNews, nuestro boletín gratuito para toda la
comunidad de VisualPolitik. Os enviaremos cada
semana 2 boletines analizando todos los
principales acontecimientos que explican
la actualidad mundial. Desde la política al
mundo de la economía y las grandes finanzas.
¿Todavía no lo conoces? Pues… Puedes
suscribirte en www.notnews.com.
Y si te gusta lo que hacemos, quieres
apoyarnos y encima recibir más boletines,
merchandising y un montón de cosas que
estamos preparando súmate también a
nuestra comunidad de Patreon. Os dejamos
todos los enlaces en la descripción.]
Dicho esto, continuemos, porque hay
más: está lo mencionado en Siria,
donde Al-Asad les prometió el 25% de
los campos petroleros que liberaran de
manos de los kurdos apoyados por Estados
Unidos, pero también Libia, Mozambique,
Sudán... En el Kremlin están encantados, porque
Wagner está aumentando la influencia rusa sobre
África en detrimento de otras potencias como
Francia. Y al igual que crece la influencia rusa,
los negocios de Prigozhin no paran de crecer.
Acostumbraos a ver titulares de este tipo:
(Cómo los mercenarios rusos se están apoderando
del comercio de diamantes africanos )
Tal es el ascenso de Prigozhin
que en la propia Rusia está
generando preocupación… entre los silovikí.
Recordad que Prigozhin no es uno de
ellos. Genera recelos y los silovikí lo
ven como un antiguo delincuente reconvertido en
oligarca. Su relación con Prigozhin está repleta
de altibajos. La prueba es que su éxito comenzó en
San Petersburgo, ciudad dominada por los silovikí,
sin embargo sus negocios empresariales han
prosperado en Moscú. Por ello Prigozhin siempre
ha sido muy crítico con las autoridades de San
Petersburgo. Más aún desde el pasado verano,
cuando Megaline, otra de sus empresas, se
quedó fuera del desarrollo de Gorskaya,
un macroproyecto que ahora ejecutará
una empresa vinculada a Gazprom.
("Megaline" asegura que Smolny rescindió el
acuerdo sobre el desarrollo
del territorio "Gorskaya")
Smolny es la sede del gobernador
de San Petersburgo. Actualmente
está ocupada por Alexander Beglov,
un protegido de Sergey Kiriyenko,
la mano derecha de Putin para la política
interior rusa. Por eso Prigozhin se está
implicando tanto en la guerra de
Ucrania. Victorias en Ucrania se
traducen en más influencia en el Kremlin.
Pero también en más enemigos. Atentos.
T3 (PELEA DE GALLOS)
A estas alturas no hace falta saber mucho
sobre la guerra, sobre todo en su primera fase,
para entender que las cosas no han ido como el
Kremlin había planeado. Rusia intentó tomar Kiev
por la vía rápida y fracasó. ¿Qué hizo entonces
Putin? Pues al mes y medio de invadir Ucrania,
recurrió al grupo Wagner. Putin conoce
al dedillo el historial de Wagner y sabe
que sus hombres están curtidos en mil
batallas. El problema es que el chef
de Putin se ha guardado sus mejores
ingredientes. Y a Ucrania ha enviado
a miles de convictos básicamente
con una promesa: libertad o muerte.
A la vista de los continuos fracasos de su
ejército, Putin le dio a Wagner libertad de
actuación después del verano. Fue entonces
cuando Prigozhin recurrió a los veteranos de
Wagner para llevarles a Ucrania a liderar a
los miles de mercenarios recién reclutados,
desplegados en el frente después de un único
mes de adiestramiento. Nos encontramos,
por tanto, con tres cabezas al
frente de las fuerzas rusas:
en primer lugar, el Ejército ruso,
dirigido por silovikis de manual:
el ministro Shoigu y el General Valery Gerasimov.
Serán muy tecnócratas pero están fracasando.
Después tenemos a los KADYROVSTVY, dirigidos por
el líder Checheno Ranzam Kadyrov. Tampoco pueden
presumir de grandes victorias. Y, finalmente,
tenemos al Grupo Wagner: los únicos que sí
pueden mostrar algunos resultados. Peleando
metro a metro, las fuerzas rusas han empezado
a recuperar terreno en el Donbass. Y Prigozhin
no ha dudado en atribuir todo el mérito a sus
mercenarios y criticar abiertamente al Gobierno.
Aquí podéis escucharle mientras veis a los
mercenarios de Wagner practicando tiro
con dos generales rusos en la diana.
Estas 3 cabezas de las fuerzas rusas
están compitiendo para hacer méritos
ante Putin. El presidente ruso ha pensado:
pues oye, mientras estos luchan entre ellos,
no se ponen a discutir si yo debo
seguir siendo el líder supremo. De
esta forma están motivados para entregar
victorias a Rusia. Y efectivamente,
eso es lo que está sucediendo. Las victorias más
recientes de Rusia en la guerra de Ucrania han
llegado de la mano de Prigozhin: ahí está
Soledar y así parece que será con Bakhmut.
Ahora bien, para cortar la creciente influencia
de Prigozhin, en enero el Kremlin relevó como
comandante en jefe para Ucrania a Sergey
Surovikin, general próximo a Wagner. En su
lugar colocaron al propio Gerasimov, fiel
aliado de Shoigu. Además, el Kremlin ya
no permite a Prigozhin reclutar en las cárceles.
Todo esto explica los ataques que Prigozhin están
lanzando contra el Gobierno ruso y los silovikí;
ve cómo su influencia sobre Putin está en peligro.
Así que ya veremos qué sucede en los próximos
meses. Imaginad qué dirá Prigozhin si sigue
siendo el único que consigue victorias para
Rusia. Pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros:
¿Creéis que el grupo Wagner será decisivo
para decantar la guerra? ¿Puede ser Prigozhin
el sucesor de Putin? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios. Como siempre,
si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale a
like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
¡Ah, importante! No te olvides de
echarle un vistazo a Notnews.com.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.